what are your thoughts on ozempic
um it's a prescription medication that
is used to delay gastric emptying which
AIDS in weight loss and treatment of
diabetes
right and what how do you feel like do I
have emotions about ozempic uh what what
I'm that doctors it seems to be and
maybe I know you're you're in New York
but here in LA
no New York it's a hot thing too oh okay
so celebrities are rushing to get it
it's not only celebrities but it's just
well people who are in front of a camera
are the people that we hear about but
even I know people and people in in your
school and things like that like other
parents and things like that my school
all my kids school yeah yeah well she's
she was a teacher
but but what I'm saying is people I know
that just want to lose five pounds
they're not on uh television they're not
modeling
um are jamming themselves with ozempic
and it I know somebody who's not on TV
that went to a doctor female went to
their general practitioner and said uh
if you want some mozambic you know I'll
give you a little prescription they
didn't even this is enough to uh maybe
make somebody start to uh get an eating
disorder because they weren't even
asking for it so it's being offered so
my couple of questions about ozempic is
are these companies off I find that the
doctors are shelling it out are you get
do you get a kickback no absolutely
absolutely not so the sale pardon me
illegal
star claws are already in effect to
prevent that from happening there's what
they're called Stark laws explain to me
what that is
um it's basically a law that prevents
doctors from profiting profiting off of
the prescription of medications owning a
lab and sending the patients only to
this lab
um sending them only to a specific
sub-specialist that they get kickbacks
from there's rules in place against this
there is no benefit to a doctor
prescribing anything there is uh it's
secondary benefit from patients coming
to see them and paying out of pocket
costs to see them
and if they can create a business
surrounding that and saying oh if you go
see Dr X Dr X will give you whatever you
want you'll pay whatever the fee doctor
X charges you I saw a video that you
made about the dangers of also really
wealthy people in their health care not
being
great because of this issue and going to
concierge services and because they're
able to
um do what you're saying and there's not
as many regulations yeah so if you look
at it our Health Care system is messed
up on both ends the bottom part of our
socioeconomic ladder people struggle to
get access to care they can't afford
their medications they can't see doctors
because they don't have insurance but
then on the other end they also get
really bad health care because they
think they can buy Health you cannot buy
Health you cannot with billions of
dollars say I want to make sure I never
die I want to live forever hyper
optimization does not exist in
healthcare no matter what medical doctor
social media influencer tells you the
enemy of good in health care is trying
to be perfect because the body's job is
to stay in balance and homeostasis and
the second you're going into hyper
optimization that's an extreme the body
will have a pushback effect and you'll
have side effects therefore the body
does not like hyperoptimization
which an example is like juicing a juice
cleanse or
um like when people say oh if you take
trt you'll be faster stronger leaner and
everyone should be on trt well hold on a
second that's hyper optimization yes if
you have low testosterone because of
hypogonadism which is how we call it in
medicine then you should consider taking
typo gonads gonadism
yeah because the gonads produce
testosterone so if you have your own ads
you're nuts
right I'm putting it in layman's for my
daughter it's hard to talk to your
daughter about your nuts birds and bees
[Music]